Nicolas Mesly est avec nous.
Vous êtes journaliste, agronome,
vous êtes derrière ce
documentaire-là. Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir à vous.
- Alors on croyait, certains
croyaient peut-e depuis
Jean Garon à l'époque, c'était
réglé, cette histoire-là.
On a une Commission de
protection des terres agricoles
au Québec, puis on disait on di:
Bon, bien, tout va bien,
on peut dormir tranquille.
Ce n'est pas le cas.
NICOLAS MESLY, journ. et agro.,
doc. "Québec, terre d'asphalte"
- Non, écoutez, il y a un peu un
vice de conception dès le départ
si on veut dans la loi de
la pro territoire
agricole. Il y a une loi
qu'on dit nationale, l'intérêt
national, la protection des
terres agricoles. Mais ce qu'il
faut comprendre, c'est que le
moteur, le bulldozer économique
qui passe sur nos terres
agricoles, le carburant de ça,
t les taxes municipales.
C'est la fiscalité municipale.
Donc, on a, si vous voulez,
on a première couronne, deuxième
couronne, troisième couronne,
surtout dans la CMM,
la Communauté métropole
de Monez
des municipalités qui se
concurrencent entre elles
pour des projets immobiliers,
pour des parcs industriels
et vous avez aussi, avec le
développement des routes, des...
je vous dirais des investisseurs
extrêmement patients qui sont
ués, qui aués, qui aués, qui aue
que la route passe, finalement.
Et a cà, ça, ça crée
tout le temps, je vous dirais,
il n'y a pas meilleur... presque
pas meilleur investissement
qu'une terre agricole. Quand
vous avez un boom immobilier, on
va construire, quand les maisons
tent trop cher, on va
construire d'autres maisons
pour faire baisser les prix.
Mais quand on est dans
les terres agricoles, c'est
une ressource non renouvelable.
Donc, il y a quelque chosede tru
sens où, aujourd'hui, les terres
agricoles coûtent tellement
cher, parce qu'il y a de la
ation, pour de nombreuses
raisons, surtout comme la dame
l'a dit dans le documentaire,
l'agriculteur, il a le choix
de la vendre. S'il n'a pas
de relève, bien, il la vend
au gros prix, au pied carré.
- Dans votre documentaire,
c'est très clair, vous dites :",
les terres agricoles, ce n'est
plus rentable de faire, dans
plusieurs cas, de l'agriculture
dessus.
- Bien regardez, si on le prend
au niveau économique, on est pas
mal rendu dans un cul-de-sac,
au sens où l'agriculteur, son
principal outil, c'est la terre.
Quand c'est rendu, en
particulier la relève agricole
n'est pas capable de se payer
, qui est
contaminé par la spéculation,
où des gens qui sont capables
d'acheter des terres à plus haut
prix qu'une terre nourricière,
il faut distinguer ici la valeur
agronomique d'une terre,
la valeur agronomique, c'est
ce que je suis capable de faire
pousser dessus, un bon sol,
le taux d'ensoleillement...
Mais les gens, la différence de
culture, si vous voulez, c'est
que les promoteurs vont la voir
en pieds carrés pour faire des
entrepôts, pour faire des
condos, pour faire ce que vous
voulez, tandis que l'autre,
l'agriculteur, il l'achète
en hectares. Juste pour vos
auditeurs, 1 hectare, mettons,
c'est trois quarts d'un terrain
de football ou 17 terrains de
tennis pour les sportifs.
- Oui, la rentabilité n'est pas
la même, la rentabilité n'est
pas la même.
- C'es
- Monsieur Mesly, vous êtes allé
à Laval, vous êtes allés à
Blainville, sur la couronne
nord, à Mirab
un premier extrait à Laval où
Monsieur Forget, l'agriculteur,
le producteur maraîcher, vous
expliquent qu'il commence à être
encerclà,là,là,là,là,là,là,là,l,
les maisons ne veulent pas vivre
à côté des terres agricoles.
C'est lui qui est devenu
l'étranger sur son sol. On
écoute
- Elles n'ont pas d'affaire là,e
agricole, il n'est pas supposé
y avoir de maisons.
Mais elles sont là.
Les premiers propriétaires
étaient conscients qu'il y avait
une ferme à côté d'eux autres,
tout ça. Et là, les...
Ça a changé, ça a changé, ça a
changé. Puis là
qui aime la campagne, mais pas
les désagréments de la campagne.
Puis la valeur foncière a
tellement augmenté que quand
tu achètes un
de 250 000, 300 000, 400 000,
et que ça sent la marde...
c'est plus fâchant un peu.
En gros, l'enclavement, ce
qu'on mme le
début de la fin. Ils bâtissent
autour de toi pour t'isoler. Et
un coup que tu es isolé, c'est
toi qui deviens la nuisance.
- Combien on en a perdues,
de terres agricoles, depuis
10 ans, par exemple?
- Depuis 10 ans, ce qui est
officiel, on a perdu environ,
d'après l'UPA et la commission
de protection du territoire
agricole, environ 10 000 ha.
1000 ha, c'est 100 fermes
moyennes au Québec.
- Donc, c'est énorme. On
continue à en perdre. Et je vous
repose la question. Monsieur
Forget à côté de lui, pourquoi
on a réussi a dézoner des coins
où ie terre?
- Bien là, le champignon que
vous voyez, l'étrange champignon
de 40 maisons, ça, ça a été fait
avant la loi de la protection du
territoire agricole. Mais la
pression s'exerce encore.
Au bout de sa terre, on veut
construire, au nom de la
croissance démographique, une
station multi pompe. Alors qu'il
en existe tout près. Alors une e
qui va contaminer ses champs.
En plus, ce monsieur-là, il fain
humaine. À un moment donné, je
veux dire. Les Forget que vousvt
un surnom. On les appelle les
gaulois de Laval. Ce n'est pasps
tout le temps. Tu es tout le
temps en train, si vous voulez,u
n'avais pas assez de produire
de la nourriture.
- Dans votre documentaire, ce
qui est fascinant, c'est que
vous appelez, il y a toutes
sortes de pancar
quand on va dans le nord, il y a
des pancartes à vendre en pieds
carrés. Vous  appelez, vous vous
faites
est intéressé, et on vous dit:
c'est zoné agricole, mais si
vous êtes patients, ça va être
dézoné et ça va valoir 20 fois
- Exactement. Alors, la
commission, vous parliez de la
commission de la protection du
territoire agricole, ils fontoss
avez une terre enclavée, non
seulement vous avez une terre
enclavée qui va être difficile
à cultiver, mais c'est
il y a de moins en moins
d'agriculteurs. Qui va aller
s'installer là et qui peut
payer? Alors, les municipalités,
si vous voulez, pour acheter
à ce prix-là les terres qui sont
vendues.
- L'autre versant, puis on levo,
l'ancienne mairesse de
Boisbriand, on va l'écouter,
vous dit, oui, m
Mesly, ça fait 40 ans dans
certains cas, il y a un projet
et pourtant domi
Boisbriand, la mairesse vous
dit, on ne cultive plus là
depuis 50 ans, o
VOIX DE MARLENE CORDATO,
mairesse de Boisbriand
- Bien
bien connaître le territoire
de la ville de Boisbriand.
Ce territoire-là, qui esté entr,
640 et le... la route 344,
il faut aussi savoir que...vaitr
une partie; tout le reste des
terres a toujours été en frichee
à Boisbriand et ça fait plus
longtemps que ça que ces terres,
elles ne sont pas cultivées.
- Puis, ils arrivent avec
des super projets de 100-200
hectares. C'est supposé être
le projet écologique, avec
l'agriculture intégrée dans
le projet. Mais dans le fond,
c'est de l'asphalte, du ciment,
des maisons et des jardins
qui... vont-ils suffire,
autosuffire à un projet?
- Parce que tu as Boisbriand, le
projet on l'a beaucoup arrangédy
avoir des jardins, de ceci, de
cela. Je vous pose la question
que la
on ne les cultive pas ces
terres-là, pourquoi ne pas en
faire des maisons, il y a des
gens qui veulent y habiter?- Bie
agricole. Dans le fond, ce
projet-là, Quartier Forestia,
c'est qu'on voulait, on peut
passer de l'agriculture urbaine
dans un projet domiciliaire.
Combien de temps ça peut durer
encore construise d'autres
choses dessus? Donc, ont dézone
une zone agricole pour faire, ce
qu'on disait, de l'agriculture
urbaine. Je trouve qu'il y a là
une certaine malhonnêteté. Si
vous gardez ces terres-là, et
que vous avez des jeunes
agriculteurs qui souhaite étable
raisonnable quand je vous
parlais d'outils, Madame
Cordato, je lui ai demandé le
prix, à combien ça se v
cette terre-la. 30 ou 40
millions qu'elle me disait.
Écoutez, qui peut s'acheter ça?
- Voilà. Alors c'est, je le
répète, vous
travail fascinant, parce que
dans le débat actuel sur
davantage d'indépendancetaire, a
réalité, on ne va pas du tout
vers ça. On continue àpper des à
favoriser l'étalement urbain.
Elle est où la solution entermi?
- Je vous dirais que la solution
c'est... ça prend, ça vient d'en
haut, ça prend un poing sur latr
peut-être une zone verte mais
immuable. On a plus à s'en
inquiéter.- Immuable?
- Immuable. Bien c'est ce que
fait un peu la ville de Toronto.
Et je voudrais même Vancouver et
même Ottawa jusqu'à un certain
point. Donc on à s'inspirer,
nous, Québécois, de ce qui se
passe un petit peu ailleurs.
- Encourage les gens a regardé
ça : "Québec, terres
d'asphalte". Vous avez déjà
intéressants, tendres, des
producteurs maraîchers, il y a
une productrice laitière
également. Il y a des gens qui
ont une longue expérience
Laval, sur la rive nord de
Montréal. Merci Monsieur Mesly.
C'est a 20 heures ce soir
Mesdames et Mess
Merci de nous avoir parlé.
- Merci à vous, bonne soirée.
- Au r